hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcasts small refinements equal large
enhancements to science and animal
welfare I am Judy O'Rourke of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's webcast is presented by
Labrinth com the we shall be the leading
social media site for science
professionals before we start there are
a few instructions this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
race continuing education credits after
the webinar is over and to get your CD
credits click on the CD button located
in the bottom left hand corner of your
web page and we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answer is welcome to you can do
this by hitting the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today want a better look you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issues now let's get right
to today's presenter we are proud to
welcome let Eevee Medina DVM diplomate
of the American College of laboratory
animal medicine and director of Animal
Welfare and compliance for AB be
incorporated dr. Medina earned a
bachelor's of science and biology at the
University of Notre Dame and a DVM
degree from Texas A&M University she
completed her laboratory animal medicine
postdoctoral training at the University
of Illinois in Chicago dr. Medina serves
as the director of animal research and
compliance at abbvie her primary
responsibilities are to ensure that ad V
adheres to all animal regulations adopts
the most ethical animal research
practices and continues to enhance an
ethical culture for animal research with
innovative 3 R's initiatives she has
served this chair of the 3 R's
leadership group of innovation and
quality and drug developed
consortium in 2014 and as a co-editor
for the 3 R's special topic journal
published by Jay last March 2015 dr.
Medina is dedicated to promoting more
transparency about ethical animal
research to ensure public understanding
and support for biomedical research she
is a frequent speaker national meetings
about animal welfare the 3 R's and the
need for public outreach I will now turn
it over to dr. Medina for her
presentation good afternoon everyone I
think the people I'll be presenting two
are in the afternoon hopefully so thank
you for attending this talk I'm going to
just go through kind of an overview of
what I call small refinements which can
lead to large enhance enhancements to
science and welfare so I like to look at
it as a holistic approach to the way we
do work starting with the way we
transport the animals and receive them
in char facilities how we acclimate them
and then all the way through the process
of caring for min ritching their lives
the way we handle them and different
oversight procedures as well as trying
to advance the three hours whenever
feasible so when we talk about
optimizing animal care and use practices
you know we have to think in a holistic
manner so it's not just animal care
staff that are caring for the animals
every day it's not just the
veterinarians it's everybody the
researchers and the ayah [ __ ] staff they
all have an important role to play to
ensure that our practices are optimized
and to reduce unnecessary pain and
distress and so if we strive for
uniformity and best animal care
practices
we have consistent humane animal study
techniques and we really strive to dr.
three RS when they're feasible then I
think again we're all working together
to optimize that animal care use please
just a reminder that anybody can ask a
question in the middle of the talk and
I'll try to stop an answer if you have
any questions so starting at the
beginning with transportation how do we
optimize transportation to enhance the
welfare of our animals so you know I
don't know how many of you take the time
to review the transportation log you
know the food the water you know how how
the animals been observed on though if
it's a long transport that they've come
you know from a very far distance to
your facility and it's our obligation in
a sense to point out gaps if our
transfer transportation companies maybe
you know aren't doing everything to our
specifications so we have to work with
them to optimize the care of the animals
things to consider like for rabbits
we've learned this in our own facility
that when possible because a lack is now
emphasizing you know pair housing or
group housing of most species as the
default for rabbits that tend to fight
quite a bit you know we've had success
ordering younger siblings when we have
to bring in more than one rabbit at a
time and to transport them in pairs so
that they can remain together and then
you have less fighting we also try to
get immediate weights on those rabbits
since they tend to be a little stress
from the transport and they can lose
weight you know that first week as
they're getting acclimated to a new
environment another trick to kind of
keep in mind to work with your transport
companies is if there's stormy weather
happening you know do they use white
noise or music to kind of calm the
animals so that they're not quite so
startled by you know loud thunder and
things like that and then just a log of
adverse events a few times we've had our
comparative medicine group come and talk
to the aisle
some incidents that have occurred some
welfare issues that were not handled
optimally by the transport company and
so again then the iock up will work with
the transport company to make sure that
we're reducing the likelihood that that
kind of adverse event will happen again
when we're receiving animals with
regards to receipt of animals how do we
receive them so with dogs we've come up
with a pretty interesting way to do this
by actually allowing volunteers who
don't work in the animal program day in
day out but who just love dogs they come
and volunteer with our animal care staff
to help cut the dogs and interact with
the dogs because the dogs are a little
nervous when they first arrived and it's
a wonderful way to get those dogs you
know brought in in a more optimal way I
know that's maybe not feasible for all
the programs that are out there but it's
been a real success here at Abdi and I
would certainly encourage you to
consider it I'll talk a little bit more
that about that kind of thing later
another thing you know with non-human
primates if you're working with
non-human primates just making sure that
you're looking at the food in the crates
and looking at their feces do any of
them have diarrhea are they you know
possibly going into a state of not
wanting to eat because of the stress
just so you can be prepared to you know
keep a better eye on when they come into
the facility and then just to optimize
the arrival and receipt of surgically
altered animals having veterinary staff
there to kind of look at the incisions
as we're in creating them and making
sure that if there are any maybe some
you know open wounds or things that have
gotten you know a little bit traumatized
during the transport that we deal with
them at a very proud manner um so just
things to keep in mind you know is your
Iook i conformed when arriving animals
experience health or other complications
I do think that is something that we
should make sure that we do
our I attacks know so that they can help
to manage that if it needs to be
addressed in any form or fashion and
then just again shipping those pairs
when you can with the rabbits and then
reviewing the process for all the
species because they're all going to
have different transportation needs and
making sure that we're partnering with
the transportation companies to optimize
things as best as possible okay so when
it comes to the next thing acclamation
so obviously in the guide it's very
clear you know we all know that newly
received animals should be given a
period for physiologic behavioral and
nutritional acclamation animals
typically need a minimum of 24 hours for
rodents and 72 hours for larger animals
obviously some programs will establish
more of the standard 72 hours for all
species you know a three-day acclimation
period is not uncommon but I think it's
very clear that acclamation has been
demonstrated for a very large number of
species these are some of the references
in the guide and make sure that you know
you really have a pretty consistent way
of dealing with with that so you don't
have animals coming in and going
straight on study which is an optimal to
the science or the welfare so some of
the considerations again do you have an
SOP for each species or for all the
species in one that's okay however you
want to deal with that one of the
examples that I'll give from my program
is that we put rabbits on a feeding
schedule we have a sticker that we put
on their cage cards as soon as they come
in just so that they because they're
given a slow acclimation to going on
increasing feed ration over several days
so that they can kind of manage the
stress in their response to maybe not
eating as much and they don't get upset
stomachs when they come in and making
sure again that your Ida [ __ ] is in on
the loop and reviewing those kind of
guidelines as new information and
science is done on these different areas
of you know the impact of stress on
animals moving on to husbandry some
really important things to consider
with food very recently you know I many
of you may already know this and maybe
you've dealt with this in your own
program but we just recently in the last
several months have been dealing with
this a little more acutely and that is
because we're a pharmaceutical company
and we have by animal vivariums at
several different places around the
globe both in the United States and
outside of the US what we've realized is
when we were doing similar studies in
one site to another site that we were
having some different data outcomes as
something as simple as you know that the
drug levels we are meshed measuring and
when we looked at the comparison of how
we house them and how we manage them it
came down to the food and the soy based
diets were effecting a difference making
a difference in the in the data we
collected so we recently saw plasma
concentrations reduced in my son soy
diets and the theory is that the soy
induces the sip enzymes in the liver
leading to faster metabolism of the
drugs and obviously that can be a real
big impact on pharmaceutical research
because we want to know what the what
the plasma levels are and how they're
likely to translate into human clinical
trials you might want to you know look
at this reference that I put up there
from West mark from 2013 even saying soy
based diets exacerbate seizures and
mouse models so we have to really be
thinking about the bigger picture for
these things and how they impact the
science here's some of the data that we
collected internally that when we
compared soy bean meal in red with a
corn gluten meal added to normalize the
amount of protein the soybean the
animals on soybeans still had lower
lower plasma concentrations of the drug
compared to the animals on the corn
gluten meal you know the non soy diets
so again please can keep that in mind as
you oversee your your individual
programs
other things to consider from a welfare
perspective with food or is just caloric
intake obviously this is something that
I think we all have to deal with with
all the different species we handle
especially if you have chronically
housed animals I've certainly seen
problems with obesity in rabbits in rats
in dogs and in monkeys I've seen it in
other species too but these four that I
have listed on the slide are the ones
that I've had the most concern with
because obviously with rabbits and rats
the obesity can lead to foot problems if
their house long-term with the monkeys
and dogs you can get metabolic syndrome
or type 2 diabetes all of these
obviously are not optimal for welfare
and they can affect the the science and
the research that's being done and so if
we can control the feed intake and limit
it the animals are you know maintaining
much better body weights and I think
again it's something that sometimes we
do a great job and depending on the size
of your program it might be a little bit
more challenging in some of our programs
something as simple as bedding so a
number of years ago back in two thousand
eleven and twelve we are comparative
medicine animal care staff group decided
that they were going to change bedding
from Aspen ship bedding to corn cob
bedding because the corn cob bedding was
going to save money and it was going to
be more absorbent and they thought that
it was going to be better for the
animals well well and behold um several
of our research staff quickly came to
the you know the Animal Care Group and
started saying our data our research
data is not working right now since we
made the change to this corn cob bedding
and so you'll see that um this one
publication by raw relays and Steve
McGarrity that the rats housed on corn
cob bedding show less slow-wave sleep
and we publish that in jail ass back in
2012 and if you look at the red arrow
the low amplitude waves from the EEG
rats show that they're awake so the rats
on
corncob bedding in the left graph we're
getting less sleep than the animals on
the Aspen ship betting over the same
time period so that was enough for us to
go wow this is affecting not only this
model it also affected a pain model that
we were doing some research in and we
had to go back to the Aspen ship bedding
and we as an ayah [ __ ] decided to make
make the guideline that we would not use
corn cob bedding in our facility based
on this scientific data that it was
really causing problems for several
different models so keep that in mind
when you start looking at temperature
and lining something as simple as you
know the lighting Kenneth in the
temperature they can affect the
physiology and so we've had several
instances where we have aged animal
models and when they start getting older
and they're you know starting to have
some old age issues you know maybe their
renal function isn't as optimal I'm just
like older people you tend to start
having more you know cold temperature
stress and feeling the cold you know in
your body a little bit more so what
we've noticed is that if we just
increase the room temperature just a
little bit for those rooms that have
aged animals like age of rodents in
particular it can make a real difference
to them feeling a little bit more
comfortable based on behavior that we
can assess and maybe you know decrease
the problems that we see I think many of
you have probably seen this article from
2013 about individual individually
ventilated cages and how they can impose
cold stress on lab mice so it's
certainly something for us to keep in
mind and then this other publication in
2013 by Briana Gaskell was about the
impact of nesting material on mouse body
temperature and so making sure that
we're giving enough nesting material so
that the mice can build good nests and
they can find warmth inside those nests
and they can maintain their physiology a
little bit
easily has has really been shown to be a
very positive thing for the animals who
do that nesting on in the natural
environment let me look at lighting so
obviously we all know that photo period
is a critical regular regulator of
reproductive behavior in many animal
species and so inadvertent light
exposure during the dark side well [ __ ]
you know has to be minimized or avoided
there was this really good article in
2011 about eliminating animal facility
light at night or they called it LAN and
its effects on the circadian regulation
of Rome and physiology tumor growth and
metabolism and so they were trying to
relocate a cancer research lab from one
place to another and they had to really
figure out how to minimize light effects
on the tumor growth and so again a very
good article to look at something as
simple as some of these doors that we
have on the animal rooms that have a
window that can allow light in the other
thing that they showed in this article
is that a leaky door jamb that maybe our
doors are not sealed all the way around
and so light from the hallway may be
getting in and affecting some of these
rodent circadian rhythms and so again
checking the lighting system sometimes
we rely so heavily on our computerized
methods of monitoring things and we
never double check that they're actually
working to our specifications so making
sure that once in a while we come in at
night and make sure that really things
are happening the way they appear to be
happening is a really good practice so
some of the husband husband
reconsiderations just to review them
again you know has your staff considered
the impact of diet on animal models and
if you're you know are you using soy
based diets and if so you might want to
consider how that might be affecting the
drug levels if your your dosing any
avail
with pharmaceutical agents and measuring
those levels really carefully consider
that bedding because it really was a
very eye-opening experience for us when
we had the corncob issue and then just
the nesting material making sure you're
consistently giving enough so they can
build those really complex now so I know
it's a cost factor but again in the end
if you're optimizing the welfare of the
animals at stabilizing their physiology
and their ability to maintain that
thermal neutral zone you're going to
have better science coming from those
animals and then just checking the
lighting to make sure it's not exposing
these animals to unnecessary light at
night behavioral enrichment so we
recently had the great luxury of hiring
a full-time behaviorist to come and work
with us at Abby she started just a
couple of months ago we're thrilled to
have her she helped me with these next
two slides and what she wanted me to
emphasize for all of you is that you
know well conceived enrichment provides
animals with choices okay in a degree of
control over their environment which
allows them to better cope with the
stressors in their environment and that
comes directly from the guide and that
successful programs for enrichment
should incorporate multiple tiers or
layers of enrichment so that you
facilitate species specific and species
appropriate behaviors so it's more than
just throwing a toy in a cage or giving
a treat but allowing them to have some
some control so well facilitated
enrichment programs aim to increase
physical activity stimulate natural
behaviors and prevent or reduce
stereotypic behaviors you know something
as simple as what we've done in our
facility for rodents rats love to gnaw
so we have these wooden blocks you'll
see the wooden block in the center and
we had a we did a study aside by study
to compare rats on the wood blocks
versus rats without the wood blocks and
did it affect the glp absorption of some
of the compounds that we were giving the
rats and we found it didn't and so we're
able to publish on
we've also used popsicle sticks
sterilized popsicle sticks for the rats
to chew on and obviously Mike like mice
like to build nests and you know
obviously the the one thing that we all
try to do is the the social housing
because that all the animals are social
to some degree rabbits are the little
bill ones that are a little bit of an
outlier but most of the other species
get along quite well other than male
mice um this is a picture of something
I'm really proud of and this is a dog
socialization and enrichment program
that we've established a tabby um we
actually just celebrated our five year
anniversary for this program and
basically what we did was we developed a
program that we invited employees that
are not members of the research team
they're not members of the animal care
staff or the vet staff but members of
the company that are like you know
secretaries lawyers public relations
staff safety personnel all these
different areas of the company we let
them know that if they wanted to come
and enrich the lives of our dogs and be
enriched that they could be trained to
participate in this program when I
started this program five years ago I
was very nervous I'll tell you very
honestly I was nervous about it wasn't
sure if it was the right thing to do but
in the end I kept thinking there are a
lot of dog lovers out there who would
love to do this and so we did do it and
I got support from senior management to
open the doors and get them trained and
let them in and I can tell you it's been
so so much more successful than I ever
dreamed and we have new new volunteers
all the time and we train them on how to
you know go into the facility and we
assign dogs to them and they take them
to this playroom and so we basically
took one room and painted it and added a
little play area so that the volunteers
can take the dogs to this room and it's
been a great thing so I highly encourage
you to consider something like this very
innovative
so some of the behavioral enrichment
considerations do you have a coordinator
I know it's a luxury I know many of you
can't you know justify hiring a
full-time person but maybe something as
simple as an enrichment committee that's
another thing we established is an
enrichment committee so you find the
people who are really passionate about
optimizing enrichment bring them
together have been meet regularly have
them establish some standards about what
enrichment you're going to give this the
different species and be consistent and
always stay up with the scientific
literature because it's very important
that we only give enrichment that is
scientifically validated to be a real
enrichment and a benefit to the animals
we shouldn't be throwing things in there
an example for a while there were people
giving marbles to the mice that's
actually a model for stress in
neurobehavioral research and when we
realize that we quickly stop giving
marbles to the mice so there are things
we have to really be careful about and
just this is a list for you to review at
a later time if you're thinking about
how to expand your in enrichment program
training so this is another area that I
know many of us are trying to do the
best we can with training but it's a
hard area to get your arms around I know
it's certainly an area that we struggle
with and because we do not yet have a
full-time training coordinator and we
recognize that as a gap so I'll
challenge all of you to consider whether
you have a full-time training
coordinator you know is your program of
an adequate size to justify that do you
have good training SOPs I think that's a
really critical part i can I can say
that we have very good SOPs for training
we just have a struggle meet managing
the bigger program because if we don't
have a full-time person dedicated to it
do you have hands-on training for common
restraint blood collection dosing and
humane euthanasia I think those four
things are very very important to
provide handle hands-on training when
possible
because again if you don't do it right
that's what a lot of the welfare
problems arise proficiency so our high
tech has started asking for real-life
proficiency where someone has to do the
technique in front of someone who knows
you know what they're doing and they
have to verify they do know how to
euthanize humanely they do know how to
do cardiac blood collection in mice
humanely think they make sure the mice
and the rats are fully anesthetized
before they try to take the blood from
it from the heart stick doing it
perfusion a cut-down or an abdominal
incision and doing a perfusion obviously
if you're not validating that that
animal is fully anesthetized you can
cause a lot of pain and distress so we
always do proficiency observations in
some of these more challenging
techniques that are very commonly done
in many of our programs and then just
remember training documentation I know
it's hard but if it's not documented it
didn't happen in many ways right there's
no proof of it so look at your training
documentation and consider ways to
optimize that with handling and
restraint obviously we always try to
minimize the restraint to reduce stress
on the animals I tried to do as good a
job as I could with my my limited
graphic design skills we had some
scientists working in the cancer
research with mice where they have to do
a lot of IV dosing of either cancer
cells or cancer drugs potential
chemotherapeutics and so they came up
with a very simple restraint device that
is very minimal restraint and it's a
metal um it's a metal platform with a
metal 90 degree angle back and in the
back of the 90 degree vertical piece of
the metal there's a hole and so they
literally bring the mouse to the the
metal platform and they stick the tail
through the back of that vertical piece
and that way the mouse is totally
unrestrained on the other
side of that metal piece and they can
easily get the IV injection done I
thought it was a really smart way to do
it we probably should publish it because
it's just so simple but I would again be
innovative and making these restraint
devices that work for you and your
program and something as simple as just
making sure the lighting is good this
tail illuminator restrainer I thought
was a really cool thing just to help
make sure that vessel is really easy to
see since they're very tiny some of the
techniques to consider refining so with
blood collection something as simple as
a tail tip trick so if you you know I
know in the industry many people still
use a snip of the tail tip with some
sharp scissors for rats that are being
used for diabetes research or mice that
are being used for diabetes research for
the larger species in particular my rats
you can use a needle and just prick the
tip of the tail and still get a blood
glucose sample without having to snip
off the tip of the tail it's less
invasive less painful quick and easy it
works great we've certainly done it here
the other thing is micro sampling so
this is something that in the
pharmaceutical industry is very
impactful but I'm sure it can be
impactful elsewhere as our equipment to
measure different analytes in the blood
CBC's gets more sophisticated and we
don't need as much blood volume as we
used to we could possibly reduce the
amount of blood volume needed by double
checking with the people who manage
those labs saying what is them the
minimum volume a blood you need so that
we can reduce how much blood we have to
collect and possibly refine the way we
manage these animals so we were able
with a group of mice and and the PK
sampling that we do pharmacokinetic
sampling we do repeatedly we reduce the
number of mice from 33 down to three by
using micro sampling and getting much
smaller blood volumes for every time
point and we could get a whole curb in
three mice and have better scientific
data and better unless unless animals
and much more efficient process with
dosing using flexible dosing davaj
needles or tubes can be obviously less
traumatic than the metal gavage now some
people strongly prefer metal gavage
tubes because of the the ball in the end
making sure you never go into the
trachea but for the the plastic gavage
tubes can be quite useful and some
people do prefer them because they're
not quite as rigid and not as likely to
cause trauma I liked this website here
procedures with care org dot uk' I would
encourage you guys to go there and check
out even they use a soft red rubber
flexible tube for oral gavage I in the
route I've never done that that it
certainly looked like it was something
worth considering if you hadn't maybe a
smaller study to manage surgical
techniques how do we refine these
techniques to optimize animal welfare so
veterinary oversight of all surgical
animals it's what we're able to do in
our company our company is a mid-sized
animal program here in Lake County I
know this isn't feasible for some of the
really large academic programs but I
would certainly encourage you especially
with some of the rodent surgical models
that are more invasive what we did when
we were first getting her arms around
this issue is we started asking the
research staff that we made it mandatory
that they would notify the vet staff
when surgeries were being done so at
least we would know where those animals
were and how many and what the kind of
surgery was and then we would then go
and art that text would take a look at
those animals and especially if they're
doing it on a Thursday and we want it we
want to monitor those animals over the
weekend that also helps us to stay on
top of surgical clip and suture removal
and provide supportive care like sub-q
fluids or analgesics if needed so you
know mandatory proficiency demonstration
of aseptic technique and tissue handling
is something
we require in our program I think many
of you do too but not all all programs
do require that that is a really good
way to at least make sure that everybody
is on the same page with aseptic
technique and tissue handling as far as
analgesia use one of the areas that
again I think we don't have enough
publications on in the literature but
it's getting better is analgesia use so
we faced an issue here where there was
real concern by our cancer scientists
that if we gave one or two doses of
buprenorphine that their models of
orthotopic cancer research would be
affected in a negative way and that they
wouldn't be able to get the data they
needed so we were able to convince them
and work with them and partner with them
to do some side by side studies and with
the side-by-side studies we were able to
show that one or two doses of
buprenorphine did not affect tumor
growth in this strain of mice in this
with this tumor cell line we then
brought this data in front of the iock
and said based on this information we
feel that it is you know adequate to
give give analgesia to all the tumor
mice that have to go through a major
abdominal procedure and that was able to
get implemented likewise with the charts
on this table we had a il-23
inflammatory ear injection so they would
inject the aisle 23 in the ear of the
mice causing swelling of the ear
inflammation and then they would dose
the mice with anti-inflammatories to see
if they could reduce the swelling of the
year but they had to do some kind of a
mini pump surgery earlier on and so we
challenge them and said well we want me
to give analgesic for the surgical
procedure and they were concerned at
first at first because they're studying
a lot of anti-inflammatories and since
our analgesics can often be anti
inflammatory they were worried about the
effect on their data so they went ahead
and did the study and they showed again
that one or two doses of buprenorphine
there was no effect when you did that 48
hours before the aisle 23 injection so
then we were able to implement analgesia
for those animals in studies that prior
to that we hadn't gone that route
because of their concern so that the
science is really important to get it
out there and to really get the data to
prove and to reassure your scientists
that things are going to be okay as far
as animal health observations we have
language that says veterinarian or
veterinary technical staff must be
involved in observations of animal
models I've already mentioned this with
surgical models but also with
inflammation models with cancer models
with infectious disease models some of
the more challenging models eae you know
the the what-is-it allergic
encephalomyelitis that they have
ascending paralysis and the rats those
are really challenging models and you
need to make sure your veterinarians are
partnering with the research staff in
providing the best oversight and
minimizing unnecessary pain and distress
regarding supportive care to minimize
harms again just making sure that the
staff have the expertise of the species
you know hydration is so critically
important and there are so many many
options now water-based gels and liquids
that can have in nutrients added to them
medications can be added to these gels
for treating pinworms any of these
things can reduce stress because less
handling less stress better supportive
care and obviously I don't know if any
of you have ever been dehydrated I've
been dehydrated it doesn't feel good you
don't feel good at all so we have to
really maintain their hydration well
wait monitoring Addison is critically
important providing nutritional
supplements
one of the things that I saw on a recent
study where we had some real challenges
with multiple inflammatory diseases is
first we were just monitoring weight
loss from the beginning of the study
throughout the throughout the
progression but when I started thinking
about it they were young mice and they
were still on in the growth phase and so
when I started comparing their growth
rate to what the normal controls on that
study were they were even more
debilitated when you looked at their
lack of growth so I think something to
think about not just body weight loss
compared to their you know original
weight but are they gaining
appropriately for the age of animal and
they the age that they are in the
species and strain that they are
temperature modding you monitoring using
those sub-q chips or some other refined
ways to take temperature I don't know if
any of you have used I was just at the
doctor last week and they took it just
again with the on the forehead I know
that there's more and more research to
look at taking temperatures by using
some of those more advanced thermometers
that are less invasive but I haven't
kept up with all that so again something
to think about for little refinements
that we could do later on and I think
again I'm going to make this comment
with the picture at the bottom we must
ensure consistent welfare standards for
all species no matter how small because
i have to say that in my 20-plus years
in the industry I definitely think at
times there is more care given for the
larger species than for the smaller
species not because we don't care but
because maybe we're not as good at
assessing their mice or the rat as we
are at the with the dogs and the monkeys
and larger animals so just again
something that we need to challenge
ourselves to continually get better at
is really providing that support of care
for the for the rodents at all times he
made endpoints obviously this is always
a challenge when is enough enough having
those pre-study meetings with the
research staff to agree on humane
points I think is the best way to manage
this proactively agreeing that you know
a certain body weight loss or you know a
combination of things it's when we're
all going to save this is enough um the
scoring sheets are very useful now
they're impractical if it's a huge study
their impractical if you think you have
to start it from the first day of the
study all the way through so I think
again be rational when using scoring
sheets start using them when it becomes
challenging to make those humane
endpoint decisions so if your animals
start getting more debilitated you know
three weeks into the study and that's
when you're really questioning is it an
end point isn't it you know those
scoring sheets really help you to be
objective and be more consistent and
applying those humane standards I wanted
to show this example this is an Excel
scoring sheet that our vet staff
recently used on one of the more
challenging mouse inflammatory models
and the cool thing is it's a little bit
hard to see but the way they develop
this Excel scoring sheet is that when
the mice would lose a certain amount of
weight you can see on the pink bar
twenty percent loss it would highlight
and flag the mice that had lost twenty
percent of their body weight so there
are ways to make these kind of automated
to be more user-friendly and you have to
spend less time adding and subtracting
yourself because they excel spreadsheet
will do it for you so keep that in mind
and if you guys would like a copy of
this I'm certainly willing to share it
with you see
so I just was highlighting body weight
loss and then body weight suppression so
we were we were flagging both with those
with this study so I don't know how many
of you are from pharma companies but
with toc studies we certainly are
starting to try and make sure that we
consider staggering the dosing for some
of the more challenging studies so for
example instead of dosing low dose
middle dose high dose all in the same
day if we don't have enough information
about the compound to be dosed we will
ask them to dose the low dose and the
middle dotes on the first day and with
things like antibody drug conjugates
which can you can have adverse effects
about two weeks later or within the
first two weeks you may not want to dose
the high dose monkeys until two weeks
later so that you really know what's
going to happen in that middle does
group in that low dose group and if you
don't need to go to the high dose
because you see more toxicity in the
middle dose then you've really prevented
you know some unnecessary pain and
distress the other thing that we have
done at this company is we create a form
for each toc study to make sure that we
know exactly what the likely potential
toxicity is what organ is likely going
to be affected by this class of compound
and have those vets again ready to
intervene if there's likely to be
seizures because this is a CNS active
drug if there's likely to be emesis or
diarrhea because this is a cancer
compound that's going to cause some GI
upset and sloughing we need to be on top
of that and ready to intervene at a
moment's notice as far as I akak an
ethics committee oversight you know just
making sure you have those clear
guidelines that you can quickly refer
back to to minimize the harms to you
know guide how much the dose volume is
for the different species again clear
training and proficiency expectations
adverse events I hope all of you if
you're involved with ania tech that
you're getting a regular
updates from the vet staff and the whole
program about unexpected complications
that occur with the different animals
because again you may end up seeing as
an ayah cut that there are some trends
in repeat issues that need to be
addressed and something as simple as we
are having dogs that are having allergic
reactions and we we needed to have a
guideline to say how are we going to
manage those allergic reactions in a
consistent way no matter when they
occurred it's all about creating that
culture of animal welfare and you know
having refresher training to emphasize
the importance of animal welfare in the
three RS and you know enhancements to
our practices that we're never satisfied
with good enough we want to be the best
we want to optimize and we're always
looking for ways to improve our
oversight and care of the animals
something as simple as making sure you
have well-defined action levels for
non-compliance with aya cut procedures
and Animal Care and Use procedures not
to be you know like compliance police
but if you have investigators who are
pushing back on optimizing welfare and
doing things that really are what you
expect then you have to have a
consistent way of dealing with some of
those issues and so again we've created
minor moderate and serious
non-compliance levels and how we
interact with them are different levels
of you know action you know some some
are just an alert some you get a letter
of warning to say you know we're really
concerned about you know some of the
ways you've managed this and some we put
them on probation so don't be afraid to
do that so again building that culture
of welfare you know you have to be
proactive you have to be innovative we
have the great blessing of having a
full-time three hours coordinator again
I know it's a luxury that many of us
can't have we've created an alternatives
committee and that alters committee sets
annual goals to look at different three
hours options that we'd like to maybe
proactively promote across the company
across the program you know we'll do
training initiatives
things like that and that's all on a
volunteer basis so you don't have to
help have a full-time person to do that
I already mentioned the dog
socialization we adopt out our beagles
whenever we can we have a global
enrichment committee so we're consistent
we have an animal welfare committee that
really is a high-level committee to
establish company policy and then we do
recognize employees by having an award
program employees who are advancing the
three hours who are going above and
beyond we want to recognize them and
giving them Awards and really make that
well known so this is a Natalie bratcher
three hours coordinator and again I'm
very proud of Abdi being well we were
Abbott when we brought her in as a
full-time three hours person but again
we're very proud of the fact that she is
able to help coordinate and implement
implement three hours for our company
and I already mentioned the altiris
committee annual goals three hours
journal club the journal club can be
really useful because it is a
brainstorming time and we actually
started to zebrafish lab after a journal
club review of the zebrafish article we
realized that we had a gap and that we
should try to fill it with a zebrafish
lab and it's really taken off wrong it's
again something we're very proud of and
I already mentioned this we actually
have three levels to our word program
the first level we just give out a lunch
pass you know less five dollar lunch
pass I don't know if all the academic
institutions can do that but if you can
it goes far in helping people to get
motivated to continue to look for ways
to advance welfare and the three RS we
have a second level giving you know up
to fifty dollars gift certificates and
then we have a third level a word plaque
a luncheon we asked them to present on
their three hours in implementation and
we highlight the the advancement the
three hours success story in an article
across the company if you want to
consider creating an award program at
your institution please go to this jail
ass article from 2015 I was the lead
author on this
and it gives you kind of some of the
things to consider in creating an award
program for your own institution the
reality about the present state of the
three hours is that for the foreseeable
future you know drug development and
safety testing will continue to depend
on animal models right because even
though there are many in vitro systems
that are starting to get validated they
don't completely mimic the complexity of
the higher organisms so you know will we
ever get to a point where 3d organ
systems can replace animal use I have my
doubts I hope it would be great to see
that happen not so sure that'll ever
happen in my lifetime but the reality is
humane animal testing it's still
required and will continue to be
required for many many years to come and
we just have to really do our best to
minimize the pain and distress and to do
what we can so we can very much educate
the public and talk about our commitment
to ethical Science and Research so
you're just a quick summary you know we
talked about receipt and acclimation
procedures about the environment and all
the different things to consider their
about training about the techniques we
use about providing supportive care and
humane endpoints about our oversight
procedures and about that culture of
care the reality is there's so many
things we can do to tweak our program
and I feel like you know most of us know
that we're never quite perfect I'd love
to see a perfect program I have yet to
see one unless it's like a one-room
antal facility but the reality is most
of us just need to remember you know we
really can enhance the science through
small changes in the way we do things
making sure we partner with the research
scientists and do everything we can to
enhance the work and a welfare of those
animals so that we really can discover
better medicines better understanding of
science in the way the way we live so I
guess what i will do at this time is i
will open it up for questions and see if
anybody has an
questions excellent presentation dr.
Medina thanks for bringing that
information to us so before we get
started with all of your questions
here's a quick reminder about how to
adjust today questions can be sent via
than green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window and we'll get
to as many as we can so our first
question comes from Gregory at Medtronic
and he asks if volunteers are used to
calm animals such as dogs that have been
received is this documented in the
facility records and all the volunteers
then considered to have taken part in a
GOP study if the animals are
subsequently used in a glp study and I
have to okay I started talking before I
had full control so that's a good
question to my knowledge and I may be
wrong and I'll have to look into it to
my knowledge when we received the dogs
they are not yet put on a glp study at
that point so we have a protocol for
receiving animals and we do that
purposely because we don't assign every
dog that we order on to the the glp
study we actually do the physical exams
and make sure that we pick the dogs that
we think are the best suited for the glp
study and we typically leave a couple
dogs out so at that point they are not
considered to be on the study until they
have been transferred to the protocol
the glp protocol and then so it's really
a non-issue at our facility but maybe
you manage it differently and maybe you
want to consider creating a protocol for
receipt of animals so it's not an issue
for you I don't know Daniela from the
federal university of sao paulo asks how
could the ayah could help an
investigator to decide which outcome to
look for to not have to give up
analgesia
so I'm not sure I think I understand
your question so the two examples that I
gave we had cancer researchers that were
nervous about tumor growth so they were
afraid that if you gave an analgesic and
they had some literature to show why
they were concerned and the literature
was older literature and it was um
higher doses of what compared to what we
wanted to give for for a pain relief so
when they made the argument that this
scientific literature proved that they
couldn't give analgesics what we said as
an ayah caucus will know we're asking to
give a lower pain relief dose not a high
repeat dose like in this literature
source and we don't see any literature
that addresses specifically what we're
concerned about so we said we want to do
the study with you and prove
scientifically one way or the other does
one or two doses of buprenorphine at the
pain relief dose effect your tumor
growth or not and so we helped we worked
with them partnered with them to
understand their concern and then we
told them what dose we wanted to use and
that's how the study showed us that the
buprenorphine was not going to impact
their research the second example I gave
was about an inflammation model and so
in that model the mice were injected
into the ear with il-23 to cause
information and again but they were
concerned is if we gave buprenorphine at
an analgesic dose because they had to do
a surgical procedure to place a mini
pump they were afraid the buprenorphine
would affect the swelling of the ear two
days later so we said well we don't have
any proof there's no scientific
literature to support that concern get
the data and show it to us so they did
the study and they
within a week they did it very quickly
and they came back they showed us the
data and they said you know what you're
right there is no effect on the swelling
of the ear we can give pain relief and
we will adopt that recommendation so it
really is the investigators
responsibility to do the study with the
iock awkward the ethics committee has to
have the firm stance that that is the
requirement so what are the things that
we did here recently about eight months
ago we established a policy that made it
very clear that analgesia is the default
expectation for all survival surgeries
or invasive procedures and it is the
investigators responsibility to do
side-by-side studies if they are
concerned that it would impact their
research and so again that is what we're
asked to do as a committee is to set the
standard and then hold them to it hope
that's helpful agnieszka from the
institute of industrial organic
chemistry asks is there any guide or
rules about dosage selection in repeat
dose tox illogical studies knowing for
example only the ld50 of the test item
um so again okay so um I'm not sure I
can answer that question fully but what
I will what I will tell you is I'm part
of a consortium right now a 3 r's
leadership group consortium and one of
the things that we're doing right now is
we're looking at developing a guideline
on maximum dose volumes for different
species now it doesn't necessarily take
into consideration what you're asking
which is the repeat dose and the ld50
information so that that's a bit more
challenging I'm going to pull up a
reference I
know if you can see this the tax let's
see if i can get this right the
toxicologists pocket handbook this is a
good reference to consider if you don't
have it Michael Darragh wonko is the
author it does have some information in
that that talks a little bit about
repeat dose concerns and other than that
I saw a reference today and I want to
say it literally was just published in
2016 so hot off the presses and it is
dealing with it's an 82 page reference
from I want to say I could share it with
a group later maybe if you leave your
email on the whip with the group I could
possibly send you the reference
information for this guideline it
basically is dealing with excipients and
vehicles and the toxicity that can be
seen when we do dosing in the variety of
animals and so I don't know if that
would help you out that there's
certainly a lot of information that we
need to start sharing better and so I'm
certainly willing to kind of hand that
off if we gather your information on how
to contact you great okay we're going to
give people just another minute they're
formulating some questions give you a
minute to submit them
oh yes okay hang on just a minute here
okay someone is provided some
information not a question okay so if
there are no more questions I would like
to once again thank dr. Medina for her
presentation do you have any final
comments for us today dr. Medina sure so
I my final comment is just again you
know thank you for thank you for
participating in this web web training
today and just remember that again
everything we do is about you know
advancing science and medicine and
making sure that those animals are
treated ethically and we have such a
responsibility to do the best job
possible and we need to share
information better you know please I
encourage you all to you know go to
those national meetings the a last
meetings or the philosophy ting whatever
meetings you go to on the topic of
animal research and share your best
practices and publish and become those
leaders to advance animal welfare and
science so that the public that has
concerns about what we do when we work
with animals can feel reassured that
we're doing it the best way we can so
thank you so much for your time
thank you dr. Medina this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
race continuing education credits after
the webinar is over and to get your
siiii credits click on the CD button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
August 4 2016 you'll receive an email
from us alerting you when it's available
on demand and posted on let's calm
you're welcome to forward this
announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join us today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast we'll see you next time